the sub gap is less than 26,000 and I'm
going on holiday yeah dear man if you're
in treasonous already crows next episode
of why another week another meme
everyone say it with me
new week new means let's start this year
off with a epic meme stirs let's check
out what we had this time parody pants
ha that is bullying eh that's 6969
though am i right that's a sex number if
PewDiePie wore pants would he wear them
like it's or like obviously I alternate
okay stop being stupid
I'm not gonna wear the pants exact same
way to every single day that'd be stupid
you may think I have a really long
sweater no I don't have legs I'm
hovering above I'm hovering above as I
do this is how I walk
[Music]
felix is insecure about his height and
that's why he needs to be number one
because it's the only thing that can
really distract him from the fact that
he's not as tall as he wants to be so
there's been over a lot of rumors going
on after this video Woodrum me where he
forced measured me okay
just want to be clear I was hovering
extra low
that's why it's said 179 I mean 180
I'm getting a 185 no a 177 I'm getting
much okay right don't you can never
trust a sweet take it from a sweet
never trust a sweet this is lies and
nothing but likes okay
you can't mix her with your freaking
thumb what are you stupid
I'm subscribed thank you don't feel bad
about not having a girlfriend yet
remembers shrek didn't have a girlfriend
until he was thirty I'm like Shrek I'm
not sexy okay 9gag discrimination can
you imagine Shrek's penis I will rest my
tastes not the fair comparison meme
customer I see this like maybe 2018 vs.
2019 I like how everyone was on board
with this meme and then G like tag comes
out of nowhere and everyone's like well
yeah it's so terrible like shut the [ __ ]
when you realize the man on this meme
has died today can we get some efforts
in the check everyone clearly cared
about this man so much so that they will
refer to him as this man you can't win
plan Z in 10 minutes I saw a production
plan Z was the name given to the plan
Requip meant and expansion of the
Cuyahoga dammit out of all letters in
the alphabet there's no escape I can't
wait I can't only lose because of their
beliefs I've never been vaccinated for
anything God knows how I'm still alive
teamed with anti backs above gets
vaccinated for everything after 18th
birthday the mad lad survived 18 years
epic victory Royale
well done orange arrow if you think Hugh
to finish the his trilogy of livestream
with this gen minecraft christian server
we're banned from roblox but minecraft
christian server i guess i got no other
choice
oh my god what are the odds
that's amazing YouTube admits massive
oopsie but also makes a massive win see
damn wait that's illegal
wait what who's not 9 who's actually not
9 and tired fed beef what if I catch any
of you nah nine-year-olds come on
literally no one Egyptians you want
pyramids that's good that's really good
being sad about the maroon 5 in the
Superbowl being happy that nobody did
the fortnight things in the Superbowl
hey I never thought of that
what an optimistic viewpoint I
appreciate it thank you I am funny
Lola well now it's ruined you're ruined
to me congratulations
what is your main source of bear news
Gloria Borger that's my boy I'm proud of
you son pulls out meat god damn it where
did you answer this like where is this
from what kind of questionnaire is this
please get my friends amazing art to the
wire
oh it's chibi PewDiePie and mr. Bies
with slightly homosexual undertones I
liked it I liked the bedsheet oh that's
really cool I love the style where a
girl is crying we're boys cried we're
real men cried just don't forget me when
I lose to t-series that's all I will
ever ask please just be here when they
pass which they will never all right I'm
going on a holiday because I feel so
confident because I feel so confident in
my abilities that we will crush them
that's why t-series bring it ladies and
gentlemen we got him my time has come
boots played for tonight ones and a new
game comes and annihilates it
this guy's talent for making trendy
stuff die
oh god did I kill fortnight next oh yeah
was it literally the same day that's so
funny
sorry fortnight you know I had to do
with two yet I've done it too roblox and
I will do it to any other game you want
pyramids
[Music]
just because you don't make it into
Malaya doesn't mean your content is
unappreciated by the community and
that's a fact it bothers me that his
name is pointing correctly and that's a
fact there you go kids you got a new
improved version YouTube CEO admits even
her kids say the real one was screeching
big goof
you might say but a big victory real I
will say I was super surprised and very
happy to see that Susan actually
commented on my video and left really
nice constructive comments about it
about the demonization question I think
that's so cool
I'm really glad that she's engaging with
the community and actually responding to
things I didn't necessarily directly ask
her leave you the logo screensaver I
made for piers damn I should put that on
there I should put that on the thing
that looks sick that would be really
good I don't know if it looks good on
this camera though Thank You silver cat
I like you
Oreo the raccoon the real-life model for
rocket from guardians of the galaxy has
passed away at age 10 can we get some X
in the chat ah my favorite movie of
franchise of all time no I'm just
kidding I feel bad raccoons are awesome
animals and I would love to have one as
a pet one day although I probably
shouldn't moving on today is Green
PewDiePie's birthday let's wish him it
was five days ago your dumb balls pity
pie is 200 P let's give him a challenge
surprise attack you loose one health
stop cheating would you now it's not me
screw you you toxic screw you
Brad's camera Petey Piper stop making
fun of my camera what camera did you
steal from me Brad he had so much better
quality even the mic if everything was
better I'm sitting here with the sub
tier equipment except this chair by the
way this is an excellent
Italian leather chair I think that has
Kevlar inside as well the new Shrek
movies looking great oh god I'm gonna
miss all the eliten memes now that I'm
away gosh darn it yeah guys I'm doing a
speech about memes in my
class and they're nude pits to answer
the question our Imams beneficial to
society I've already talked about this
many times and memes were created by
aliens
okay you may think I'm crazy they were
created by aliens to halt the
progression of mankind so that aliens
living millions of years away from us by
the time they arrived with the formal
innovation we will have not progress
whatsoever and we'll still be laughing
at dumbass shrek memes haha I hope that
answers your question and good luck on
your speech in class Americans when the
trees start speaking Vietnamese Russians
when the snow starts speaking Finnish
martyrs yet when the closet starts
screaming in Swedish it's the worst meme
I've ever seen in my life god dammit no
video today just to give T series a
feeling of Hope excellent strategy
yeah it's working out really well so far
I'm not scared at all
like honestly easy you cpctc t series
could get their channel banned for
falsely coffee strike in this case video
our only hope
YouTube I am completely against deleting
channels but YouTube with it just this
one favor YouTube sub kappas below 100k
Elin must wants to host me review needs
to do minecraft livestream needs to do
needs more for tonight livestream guess
I'll go for a holiday so hard guys
listen I'm whispering alright
t series can hear it's a it's a it's a
trap
t series well swoop in thinking oh the
gates are open he's away and then oh but
playing X will initiate plan X now
please let plan X not be some Nazi ploy
okay
Frick I'm so sorry
come on si ellos son come in as I I'll
burn it I burn it I promise
kicking T series to save beautify and no
hold friend choice to part
leg bodies backpack arigato gozai
my leg man see this is what I'm talking
about everyone is doing the part it's
truly wonderful to see communities come
together for a greater cause of good
I've seen no one talk about this battle
going on no jack oh no well I guess this
means I have to play for at night when
the end yet to kill his channel I'm
sorry it had to be done took me three
days I hope you liked it
that's amazing I love how do you capture
the dead look in my eyes
not many people can do that very nice
thank you very much
vice did a newpsie women talk about the
worst body shaming they've ever
experienced finally a new mode you to
mock men's penis I said the 180 that
vises did I don't know where it's so so
perfect because you can just pull out
any old article from them and compare it
to their new ones
damn took me a while but we are
currently in the end game of God but
this is the end it isn't that guy just
honestly like ah trust me on this one
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be fine
what oh my god she wrapped it yourself
subscribe oh it's a painting that's
pretty good that is pretty good thank
your grandma for doing your part
can we get Felix to put this on his TV
so the media can never take about a cuts
it today I'll just spit all this point
of the TV and then I can say whatever I
want
dear PewDiePie hey man my name is Thomas
brush i'm the creator of pinstripe you
did voice acting for pinstripe pro-bono
of course I know like I return the favor
so I have this really cool idea of
making a game maybe about you and
t-series and I want to livestream the
creation I'm gonna get it done in two
weeks I pray you to dare me to make this
game
I dare you to bare meters Gary as a web
you and your audience to come up with
the ideas about this game you can post
it in the subreddit or come hang out
during the live streams in the live chat
and come up with ideas live as I'm
this game as long as this game is a 2d
platformer I can pretty much do anything
you need me to into we like the music
could do the code I can do art animation
design development dam name it I think
it'd be really cool for you and your
audience to throw amazing ideas at me
and see this game come to life I think
it's a really cool idea I'd love to see
you win the battle against t-series and
if we can do that in a video game I
think it'd be awesome
this is the last play all right check
out Atmos games
leave your suggestions let's freakin do
this that's it from me this week over
the Y now I am going away but I still
have videos prepared
that's right t-series that's right you
thought you could beat me ha got videos
prepared [ __ ] suck my dick in Swedish
meatballs thank you guys so much for all
the love and support and most
importantly of course the means see you
bros Skeets on the whole skis you want
pyramids
we got them oh you're into casos huh we
got you covered baby you want some bets
easy we got it all this game is still
relevant goddammit